Dark Phoenix ended an era for the X-Men franchise,
and unfortunately, it didn't end on a high
note.
From rotten reviews to disappointing box office
receipts, this superhero sequel is far from
super, and the writing was on the wall long
before it arrived in theaters.
Here's a spoiler-filled look at why Dark Phoenix
bombed.
In late January 2019, Dark Phoenix's test
screenings bombed dramatically.
20th Century Fox knew they had to fix it.
But in spite of extensive reshoots, including
major changes to the climax because of perceived
similarities to the ending of another superhero
film, critics still savaged Dark Phoenix,
which earned a Rotten Tomatoes score so low,
it's on par with disasters like 2015's Fantastic
Four, 2004's Catwoman, and the Titanic, not
the movie, the actual ship.
Brian Tallerico at RogerEbert.com summed things
up, simply calling the film
"...a joyless, lifeless, boring affair."
That's not good.
Even if critical response had been better,
Dark Phoenix faced an uphill battle at the
theater thanks to strong competition from
hit films John Wick: Chapter 3, Disney's live
action remake of Aladdin, and The Secret Life
of Pets 2.
And with box office juggernaut Avengers: Endgame
still in theaters, even superhero fans had
other options.
Dark Phoenix could have avoided these problems
if it had debuted in February as originally
planned, but according to reports, Fox moved
it to make room for another bomb, at least
domestically, Alita: Battle Angel.
Way to double down, guys.
You could argue that the fate of Dark Phoenix
was sealed way back in December 2017 when
it was announced that Disney was planning
to acquire 20th Century Fox.
Because that kind of made Dark Phoenix a lame
duck.
"Gross."
No, not that lame duck.
But even Howard benefits from being part of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
These days, superhero fans love shared universes.
The idea of bringing the X-Men into the MCU
is exciting.
But it also made Dark Phoenix seem kind of
pointless, as fans really just want to see
what the new Marvel version of the team is
going to look like, especially since, other
than Logan, the quality of the MCU films has
been so much higher than most of Fox's X-Men
offerings.
The X-Men series has had more ups and downs
than a roller coaster.
After hitting rock bottom with 2006's X-Men:
The Last Stand, the franchise rebounded in
a big way with the 2011 prequel X-Men: First
Class and its follow-up, 2014's ambitious
time travel epic X-Men: Days of Future Past.
But things went sour very fast in 2016 with
X-Men: Apocalypse.
Disappointing fans and critics alike, the
film was poorly received and failed to break
even at the domestic box office, earning most
of its money overseas.
As a result, Dark Phoenix started in a hole
to begin with, as it had to convince viewers
to return to a franchise that had already
disappointed them, and it clearly failed to
do so.
One of the most disappointing aspects of Dark
Phoenix is the relative absence of Quicksilver.
A fan favorite who stole scenes in both Days
of Future Past and Apocalypse, Quicksilver
is sidelined early on in Dark Phoenix and
gets almost no screen time.
There's not even a resolution to the long-running
subplot that he is secretly the son of Magneto.
And then there's the absence of Wolverine.
On the one hand, Hugh Jackman made it clear
that he's done playing Logan, so there's basically
no chance he would have been in the film.
"Eventually, you're going to hang up the claws,
and it's going to make a lot of people very
sad."
"Huh?"
On the other hand, well…Dark Phoenix really
needed him.
The only real argument otherwise is the fact
that even Jackman couldn't save things the
last time they made a movie from this story.
Speaking of that...
Dark Phoenix loosely adapts the classic Marvel
storyline "The Dark Phoenix Saga."Sound familiar?
"It's Phoenix.
Phoenix Dark.
Dirk.
Phoenix."
Well, if it seems familiar it might be because
the same story was also adapted in 2006's
X-Men: The Last Stand.
Yes, despite more than 55 years worth of stories
to choose from, Fox for some reason decided
to adapt the same story twice, even though
The Last Stand was widely disliked by fans
and critics alike.
Why repeat the same mistake?
It's just weird.
With X-Men premiering in 2000 and Dark Phoenix
acting as the series finale, the X-Men franchise
is ending as it's just about to turn 20 years
old.
It's arguably ending later than it should
have.
The box office landscape has changed a lot
since X-Men was first released, and franchise
fatigue has set in.
Marvel has the benefit of multiple franchises;
you don't get tired of the Avengers, because
in between those films you get the Guardians
of the Galaxy, or Black Panther, to mix things
up.
But at Fox, it's all X-Men all the time.
If anything, spinoff hits like Logan and Deadpool
proved just how tired the X-Men formula has
become, as both of those movies succeeded
by intentionally doing something different
and playing off of expectations.
Dark Phoenix, on the other hand, is exactly
what you thought, and feared, it was.
It's a sad way for the franchise to end, but
it's also a happy occasion for fans to see
the characters move over to the MCU.
It's long past due for Marvel's mutants to
come home and realize their full potential.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.